how are you doing sir
hey how lovely to see you nice to see
you
um i'm gonna start with oh sorry what
even in this crazy world
100 zoom 100 um
i have a lot of fun with this movie uh
it is
literally non-stop action like beginning
to end it slows down a few times but
it's a lot of action
um how did you pull this off the amount
of action
you have with obviously the budget you
you obviously never have enough budget
but how did you do this we prepped for a
long time so everything was kind of
meticulously planned
and um and then i think one of the keys
to kind of make the movie look as big as
it is
is we went to real locations to shoot it
you know i think when you try and make a
movie like this there are two ways of
doing it one is to
stay in a studio backlot situation put
up a big green screen shoot against the
green screen and then create the
environment
in the computer i didn't want to take
that route because i felt
it would make the movie feel a little
kind of synthetic
i knew the monsters had to be cg so i
thought everything else in the movie
should be as real as we could possibly
make it
and uh so we went to these insanely
remote
real epic looking locations and shot the
movie for real
and then inserted the creatures into
those plates that we'd shot
and i think we got not not just insane
production value but also an insane look
for the movie
by going to these remote locations and
shooting for real
and quite often a lot of these locations
were places that had never been put on
camera
before which is really exciting for me
as a filmmaker because he's so used to
going to places where other people have
shot
already to be able to go and shoot
something fresh and exciting
to create this brand new world was you
know was thrilling for me
but it was tough you know we we had to
take the whole cast and crew 350 people
and have them live in tent villages kind
of hundreds of miles away from the
nearest habitation
we put in roads we'd have to kind of dig
wells for water
um it was real kind of uh extreme
gorilla film making
but i think the you know the look we got
is pretty exceptional and pretty unique
at what day of the shoot did you realize
shooting in a desert
sucks ah day one
it didn't take very long um for a whole
bunch of reasons you know it's uh
it's hot i don't know if anyone ever
told you that but it's hot in the desert
and so for the for the actors especially
tony he's wearing all this
fur trimming on his outfits and like the
the costumes are very hot so it was very
unpleasant for the actors
and then of course they're doing all
this complex fight choreography
and um they're having to do it in sand
and as anyone who's tried to run in the
sand nose it's like five times as
difficult as
kind of trying to do a fight scene when
you're on a just a level flat
floor um so it it made everything
difficult
and then you know we'd be living in
tents and as hot as it was during the
day
you'd go back to your tent as soon as
the sun went down it will be below zero
and then generally these big storms
would come up they'd blow the tents away
or they'd knock over the windmill that
was providing the water from the well
so there'd be no water i mean it was uh
it was it was hard filmmaking
but um but i but it was very exciting at
the same time
and also for the actors it kind of put
them in
in the mindset that they were in this
new fantastic world
it felt like a kind of difficult
dangerous world they were in
because they were actually as actors
physically living it you know they
weren't kind of having to
to pretend it in front of the green
screen and then go back to their hotel
room at the four seasons
completely um i have not played the game
but i do know that the cat
uh that's on the ship is a really big
deal um
and so talk a little bit about the
importance of putting that character
in the movie and uh you know for fans of
the
of the of the video games i know it's a
big deal
well i think um i'm glad you really
enjoyed the movie and you know nothing
about the video game because that's what
we've tried to do is fashion a movie
that
absolutely works if you have no
knowledge of the game you can still come
and really enjoy
a great action adventure movie with
giant monsters
and but if you know the game the movie
is loaded with fine detail
um that that really brings the game to
life
all of the characters that mila meets
are characters from the video game
and their costumes are exactly correct
the locations are exactly correct the
monsters are exactly as they are in the
game
and most of all the palakko the chef
character that you meet
is taken directly from the game and we
consulted with the game
um makers uh the creators of the game to
actually get every
every bit of detail about him right um i
had several sessions trying to get the
pitch of his voice correct
because originally the game creator said
no no it's too high pitched then it was
too low pitched
and eventually just like the baby bears
porridge it was just right
we tried to really please um the
creators of the game because i felt they
were the gatekeepers to this property
and if
if they were happy then the fans of the
game would also be happy
i don't want to get specific with any
spoilers but i think
one of the things that i really enjoyed
was there were some twists and turns
that happened in the movie that i
absolutely did not expect um
and i don't even want to say where and
when because it will ruin things
but uh talk a little bit about sort of
not
how can i say this about um i don't
think the audience is expecting some of
the stuff that's going to happen in the
movie
well i think you know genre audiences
are the smartest audiences on the planet
i mean
and because they they they consume
movies they consume genre
they can generally be ahead of the movie
because they kind of know all the
conventions
so they kind of know where stories are
generally headed
um i shed my 13 year old daughter
inception the other day
and it was incredible because i remember
film critics being baffled by the plot
of inception some for some people it was
too complicated 10 years ago right
my 13 year old watched the first 15
minutes and then said daddy
i think this is what's going to happen
and she pitched me the entire movie she
knew nothing about it didn't even know
who leonardo dicaprio was
um so so she's smart because she watches
genre movies she kind of had anticipated
what it was going to be
so i've always seen it as my job as a
genre filmmaker to try and kind of
kind of take the audience by surprise
and kind of throw in something that
you're just not expecting
you think you know where the movie is
going to go and then it goes in a
completely different direction
and i think if you can achieve that with
a genre audience then you've really
you've really done your job as a
director
obviously why i'm curious you've made it
with resident evil there were a lot of
sequels
with this um is there thought in your
brain of if this is successful
doing more is it something that you're
really interested in i i
love the world of the game i became
involved in it 12 years ago when i
played the game for the first time in
japan
um when when really no one outside of
japan had
knew what monster hunter was it was kind
of a japanese-only phenomena
um and it's a you know it's a game
that's been going for 15 years so it's
obviously built a vast world
only part of which you can kind of um
put on screen in any one movie
so you know it definitely it's a world i
would love to return to but for me you
know i've always tried to stay focused
on one movie at a time
i think every movie has to function as a
self-contained unit
and and that's what this movie does it
tells um it tells
i think a very strong story with some
great character
work between mila and tony and a very
satisfying story
and then you know if audiences want more
then absolutely it's a world i would
love to delve back into
on that note i gotta go um seriously i
had a lot of fun with it man
i hope i hope it's a big hit for you
guys thank you so much